thank you
welcome to this meeting weber planning
committee
i will now ask the government's office
to read out domestic arrangements and
the fire regulations
thank you
thank you chair
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and the communal areas
please ensure that you wear face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you're an exempt from
doing so and that you've used the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones on
silent or switched off and that your
laptop is also switched to silent
we will be using the e-boating for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit use the stairs not the
lifts and do not re-enter the building
until it is safe to do so
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank you chair
thank you claire
introductions with us today are the
chief planning officer phil isbo
area planning ma manager mark russell
legal advisor ian depray
we have case officers rose walton and
samantha summers and joe hobbs the
government's officer is claire philpot
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitute
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor margaret mabry and councillor
simon barrett is substituting
councillor david busby and councillor
brynn huron is substituting and we also
have apologies from councillor peter
beer thank you
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
opportunity interest by members are
there any to declare
no thank you
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 16th of february
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
counselor mccraw um
para
118.17
suggests provision provision of
defibrillators i'd suggest that should
be the singular
not
multiples
yeah we can amend that
thank you
anything else
no
can i have a proposal please
thank you councillors
secondary councillor osborne
government officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
yeah i would just
amend that to reflect that small change
thank you that vote is now in progress
the same
thank you
thank you chair that's seven votes for
and three abstentions thank you
mr major have been confirmed and will be
signed to a home and men's mind copy
thank you thank you
moving on
receiving notification petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
speed
received
site inspections
chair we have two site inspection
requests and joe foster is going to
present both of them to us
thank you over to you joe
[Applause]
thank you thank you jeff
okay we have um two severance requests
um the first site visit request is for
two applications um and they are
overlapping in nature and so presenting
these two applications to you in one
site visit request and they are for two
applications that are currently ongoing
at bellevue park in sudbury
i'm just going to quickly run through
the location and the nature of the
proposals
so the first application is relating to
the park entrance demolition of the wall
and a rebuilding of new park entrance
here's the proposals just shown in
graphic form
and the second application is for the
construction 42 retirement living
apartments and the conversion and
restoration of bellevue house following
partial demolition and just to run
through the proposals here we have the
new proposed flats to the left-hand side
of the top
site
elevation there and bellevue house the
right
and just showing the other aspects
on the bottom of the slide
and the western elevation
and just to run through some quick
photos of bellevue park
just running around the site
and just seeing it from a distance
and so officers
have received quest from members and are
recommending that planning committee
undertake site inspections for two
applications given that they have um an
overlapping nature and so you can have
regard to the local circumstances that
be important for members to take into
account when the applications come to
committee
thank you chair
thank you joe
are there any questions
cancel owen first you were first
thank you jessica is that to do with the
crossing as well because you didn't
mention the crossing
um i am not um certain if that is part
of the planning application um apologies
um if it is part of the planning
applications then yes it would be to do
with the crossings as well okay and can
i can i request that we do have the um
obviously county
highways there as well please
we can certainly ask that question of
them yes thank you
thanks for asking
your question answer osborne did you
want to ask
yes thank you um mr chairman uh not
really a question it's just um
perhaps think that it's a good idea to
have the
although the um
information provided by the officer i
think is is good it will be good but i
think it's a sound a sound thing to have
a site visit to it thank you thank you
that's a harem
thank you chair is it possible for
substitutes to attend this meeting as
well please
i see no reason why not
i think as a matter of practical common
sense the as far as possible the
counselors who are going to be
determining the application would go on
the site visit i'm looking at my
governance colleague and
and
that would be your expectation mrs hobbs
i dare say
yes yes yeah
i think the answer to your question is
yes
going on for that one can i request that
um some of the subway town councillors
get invited as well please
what's what's what's our usual practice
mrs phil what i'm not sure to be honest
usually if it's in their parish or town
they would be invited but they would
just be there to
observe
i said
i just wondered if we had any indication
as to when the site visit might be
proposed
at the moment next week next wednesday
it's free at the moment
are we can i have a proposal and a
second view
thank you
can i have a show of hands with all
those in favor
have you got it
oh hang on i'm told there's a vote on
them
original electronic verbs are ready for
us yes thank you chair there is a
electronic vote ready that's now in
progress thank you
thank you
thank you members chair that is 10 votes
for
so we will
next wednesday we hope
yes yes and we have a second site visit
that um is also in close vicinity that
we're just about to present as well so
um we'll just uh discuss the perhaps
timings after the next vote
do you have one more
thank you
would you like to go ahead with that one
okay thank you and this is the second
site visit request um we have received
this planning application is um on
churchfield road in chilton outside
sudbury
and the application is an outline
application for 166 dwellings and 60 bed
care home along with
open space and
related infrastructure
just to quickly run through the site the
application site in sudbury chilton
industrial estate
and children with development just for
context
and here's the site in particular you
can see sudbury community health center
just to the corner of the site there
and just to quickly show um the site in
relation to the existing constraints
we've got the existing settlement
boundary built up area boundary there
and the site is on land identified for
employment under the current local plan
shown in pink there
just to point out um the site does have
some constraints around it i think the
key constraints the list of buildings we
have grade one
st mary's church with the
rectangle there and we have grade 2
children hall grade 2 children hall
garden wall
and grade 2 and historic park and garden
just showing the extent there
just to quickly run through the
proposals and the application is for
outline only with access applied forward
the red circles show the location of the
two access is proposed and there's also
blue circles showing the pedestrian
accesses
proposed around the site creating
footpaths
and here's the parameter plan that
accompanies the outline application just
showing the accesses the care home
location
and the residential shown in brown there
and just showing the open space ecology
mitigation area shown in green
just quick to show some photos for
context we've got the existing um
sudbury health centre there
and proposed existing access to that
health center will be the one of the
access points into the site you see the
photo locations showing the yellow and
the bottom left of the slide
just rolling around the site there
looking to the north towards chilton
hall
and looking down churchfield road
this is on great wardenfield road
residential dwellings uh just to the uh
west of the health center
and looking at great waterfall road to
b11 15.
and just looking across the site towards
chilton hall there oh that's behind the
trees and a vegetation line
just looking around the site and if you
just see um in the distance there you
can see the church of mary's church
and lastly just to show you the um
relationship the res uh the employment
area or the existing employment
buildings in the employment area
the location of that silver car is the
second access point i showed earlier
with the red
circle
i'm just showing the site to the right
of that slide
and just looking in the site back
towards the
employment units to the south side of
churchill road
so we have received requests for um site
visit from members and officers
recommend that given the site
constraints
in the surrounding area that members
undertake a site visit prior to
determining the planning application at
a future planning committee thank you
chair
thank you joe
any questions councilor barron
um as this is employment land
um i take it this has been marketed and
en 24 has been impla applied to this
site
um that will be a matter that will be
presented in the committee report when
the application is brought to planning
committee and discussed at that point
well i think it's quite relevant that we
know if we go on a site visit to look at
the employment land site which is
obviously going for residential
i think it'd be quite nice if we're
going to look at that site that we know
what the basis of the decision is likely
to be
because that
we know what site looks like it's an
employment site what we've got to
determined is whether that employment
site um the
benefit to the
public of overturning our own policy
is there so i think we need to be
a little bit more informed
of what has gone on because if there has
been no marketing plan then really this
shouldn't really be coming to to us for
a decision
because we have a policy which is quite
clear on that
um yes we can certainly um advise
members at the site visit of any points
of clarification they wish to see but my
understanding that the question today is
would members like to have a site visit
on this planning application
and obviously
those matters will be considered in more
detail once officers have completed the
committee report for the application
thank you joe i think can i ask the
chief planning officer to just chip in
at this point
thank you chairman you just just for
clarity the site visit has very defined
function within the constitution
the marketing policy that you describe
and the marketing exercise is a matter
of the
merits of demerits as you as you may
find them
from our perspective as officers they
will be reported that that issue will be
reported in the report that you is
presented to committee the site visit is
there to look at facts
that is not from my point of view a fact
that will be discernible or relevant to
a site inspection looking at the
characteristics of the land its
relationship to the surrounding areas
and the question of merit obviously is
something that will
arrive when the committee reports
presented to members and applications
come to committee all the time with
policies which are to a degree or
otherwise complied with or not complied
with the committee then judges them
thank you jim
thank you phil
any other questions
councillor you were waging
it's really an invitation one again can
we make sure that lady hart gets an
invitation please because she's chair of
chilton
parish thank you
i believe the whole parish council will
be invited
uh thank you chair can i just i i shall
be on your leave actually do i have to
send a substitute to the site inspection
not absolutely necessary but but if you
if you know who it
is them
yeah but i i don't think i'm going to
remember that okay
for
the health scrutiny so therefore i will
not be able to be there but as i live
there i know it very well but i give my
apologies now because i'll be somewhere
else
quick we haven't agreed it yet counselor
so let's
any more question to the other
council osborne
thank you thank you mr chairman i
i must add that the presentation in the
local plan from sudbury town council was
that be kept as employment land and my
concern is as uh councillor
barrett has already said is that that
will be taken away and we will
lose valuable
employment then thank you
thank you
so
thank you mr chairman can i just ask
what are the actual reasons for the site
visit rather than just members have
asked for it we usually have planning
reasons why people are asking for a site
visit
thank you chuck and answer that question
um due to the constraints surrounding
the site the proximity um to the listed
buildings and the employment area
designation of the key reasons that
members have listed in the request for
site visits
that's important
um it's a technical practical question
again and this is all about
arranging substitutes um
do i understand that these applications
that we have just agreed one for and
about to agree agree the other four
taking place on the sixth would be
determined on the following meeting on
the 13th
or is that an assumption i'm incorrectly
making it would affect it would affect
if i needed to get a substitute for the
site visit or um
what what basically i do
the answer that i think is no
to keep the answers in
can i have a proposal then if we
have a site listed council owen seconder
thank you jameson thank you
vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in
progress councilor haran
councillor barrow
thank you 141 again
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for and two votes against thank
you very much
thank you joe
thank you very much
moving on to the schedule of planning
applications
um
give the opportunity time to
swap over
just want to give
okay moving on to planning applications
we have dc
2104360 hindustan golf club
hindustan
i will now invite the case officer to
introduce the application to the
committee
good morning chair good morning members
this application is a hybrid
at hindustan golf club
comprising a full application for the
erection of a green keeper's building
following the demolition of the existing
and an outline application for the
erection of five dwellings
the village of hindusham is identified
as a hinterland village within the
babacor strategy
and therefore accommodates some
development to help meet the needs
within its functional cluster
development however is only permitted
within the settlement boundary unless a
proven and justified need is
demonstrated
this presentation is designed to provide
illustration only and must be considered
in conjunction with the associated
committee report which you should all
have had access to
moving into the main planning issues
these include the principle of
development in its location enabling
development and the impact to the
heritage assets
this is the site
with its access
this is hindusham golf club
and this is hindelsham hall
which is part grade 1 and parkway 2 star
listed
and the golf course spans over to the
east
for wider context
this is the site
with the village of hindustan to the
south
the village has some services and
community facilities
which include a community hall
saint nicholas church
a pub
primary school
and farm shop
this is the settlement boundary of
hintershim in the current weber local
plan
the site is not located within this
settlement boundary
this plan shows the location of the site
compared to the settlement boundary the
access about the boundary to the south
which is shown in orange
in terms of constraints the area in pink
is the site
to the south is the grade one hindujam
hall and its grade two star listed
stables former coach house and brewhouse
historic england also identified the
area as being historic parkland to
hindusham hall and an undesignated
heritage asset
the site and surrounding land is also
located within a special landscape area
and the green dotted line also shows a
public footpath that runs past the site
and hindelsham hall
to the south where the access starts
there are two grade two listed buildings
as well as a protected woodland and
various protected trees
moving on to the proposal
as mentioned before the hybrid
application forms two parts
full application for the erection of a
green keeper's building as well as
outline permission for five dwellings
the sale of the land with the five
dwellings is proposed to finance the
erection of the green keepers buildings
amongst other things
and which will be discussed shortly
this plan shows the proposed layout for
the green keepers building as well as
the area of land proposed for the five
dwellings
this is the proposed floor plan of the
green keepers building providing storage
for the golf club as well as a workshop
area
this is the front elevation which would
face west towards the site for the five
dwellings
this is the rear elevation which would
face east
this is the south elevation
and this is the north elevation
and this is the north elevation again
with additional planting
the five dwellings are proposed to be
located to the west of the green keepers
building as this is outlined there are
no confirmed details of the scheme only
the number of dwellings proposed
a tree nursery zone to the north has
also been proposed as well as plant into
the east and the retaining of the hedge
to the west
this is an illustrative example of a
layout and sizes of the dwellings on the
site
and an example of how it might look with
the green keepers building in the
background
this is only illustrative
as this is outlined only no confirmed
details of the dwellings are proposed at
this stage
this is the site as it currently stands
with the existing green keepers building
the owner of the golf club's house and
the golf club and the car park to the
south
this is an example of what the sitemate
looked like with the dwellings
and with the green keepers building
this is a more zoomed out shot of the
site as it exists
and this is an example of what the site
may look like with the green keepers
building
and then with the dwellings
these are the proposed site levels it
has proposed that the dwellings would be
no higher than that of the existing tree
line to the west and the existing
buildings
this is another plan showing the
proposed levels compared to existing
buildings and additional proposed
buildings serving hindustan hall which
will be discussed shortly
it should be noted that although the
dwellings would be lower in height than
the tree line and the existing buildings
there still would be a viewpoint into
the site and the roofs of the dwellings
may still be viewed from the south
looking north
and where there is no tree line
there is however a wall which we saw on
site
moving on to access
the green keepers building would utilize
the existing access and would have a
small area of new access adjacent to the
building
the existing accesses are here and here
and the new access
would be here
the proposed by dwellings is an outline
application only and therefore the
access to the dwellings is not confirmed
at this stage
access onto the site however will need
to be introduced and in earlier plans
and access was shown here
this is however not confirmed at this
stage
the application offers a pedestrian
footwear at the
access from hindustan
which the golf club have a right of
access to
there is an existing footpath on the
south side of the road and this new way
would have a dropped kerb to allow
people to cross
no formal crossing is proposed however
county highways are in agreement of this
footway
for reference
here is the site
and here is where the footwear would be
the application proposes benefits
um for the community and for the golf
club to assist in its business
the proposed benefits that may benefit
the community
include the pedestrian footway which we
just discussed
this would allow for crossing from the
access to the existing footway although
no formal crossing is proposed as well
as tree planting in the form of a tree
nursery zone
this tree planting is proposed to assist
baber in achieving its tree planting
plan as well as providing a nursery for
tree transplanting and to provide
screening
the proposed benefits for the golf club
include
the replacement of the green keepers
building which would allow the golf club
to store their golf buggies more
securely and to provide a safer building
the replacement and renewal of outdated
and broken machinery which would allow
the golf club to maintain the course and
attract new members
as well as the replacement of the
drainage and irrigation system and
extend it which would serve the golf
course and stop it from deteriorating
the sale of the land with the five
dwellings is proposed to finance these
items listed
without the monies from the sale of the
land with the five dwellings the golf
club have described a situation where
they will not be able to finance the
replacement of the green keepers
building
outdated and broken equipment and
irrigation system which is needed to run
the golf club business
this plan shows the ownership of the
land surrounding the golf club the black
outlined area shows the site of this
application the golf club and the car
park which is all in the ownership of
the applicant
the red outlined area shows the golf
course which the golf club owners lease
and they have a 99 year lease although
it is unclear how long is left on that
lease at this stage
the blue outlined area shows where the
proposed tree nursery would be located
which is leased
it is unclear at this stage how long
that lease is on this piece of land
you can see that the entrance drive and
the area of land proposed for the
footways outside of the ownership or
leased land of the golf club however
they do have a right of access over it
moving on to the heritage harm
historic england and place services
heritage share the assessment that the
development of the five hazard houses
would cause a moderate level of less
than substantial harm to the designated
heritage assets
being the grade one listed hall and
grade two star listed stables former
coach house and brewhouse and the
undesignated heritage asset of the
hindustan parkland
the open views across the parkland with
minimal built development is important
the understanding of the hall and
stables of the country house within a
large landscape park context
it is considered that although there has
already been some erosion and character
of the parkland through previous
permissions the legibility of
association between the hall stables
world garden and parkland behind is
still apparent
the heritage bodies consider that the
dwellings would erode this and alter the
hierarchy of uses on this site
historic england and the heritage team
have made an assessment that the
development of the five dwellings would
cause less than substantial harm to the
heritage assets
the impact to heritage assets is
assessed on whether it causes harm or no
harm
harm is split into less than substantial
and substantial the heritage bodies have
identified less than substantial harm in
this
case less than substantial harm is split
into three levels low moderate high
in this case a moderate level of lesser
substantial harm has been identified
which puts the level of harm here
the mppf states that when considering
the impact of a proposed development on
the significance of a designated
heritage asset great weight should be
given to the assets conservation in this
case a moderate level of less than
substantial harm has been identified and
therefore paragraph 202 requires the
harm to be weighed against the public
benefits of the proposal
the proposed benefits of the development
were discussed in
the previous slides
the site is the area in pink and to the
south is the grade one listed hindustan
hall
and it's grade two star listed stables
and former coach house from brewhouse
the land surrounding the site is also
identified by historic england as
historic parkland and an undesignated
heritage asset the solid blue line is a
public footpath that runs directly past
the site and the hall
this is an os map from between 1851 and
1952
which shows the area surrounding the
site and the hallways intuition park
which is considered to be historic
parkland and an undesignated heritage
asset
it is acknowledged that a large portion
of this parkland is now agricultural
land
the site is highlighted
sorry
it's highlighted
by the red star and the
whole grade one leicester tour was
identified by the green star
both the heritage team and historic
england have identified
less of substantial harm moderate and
scale from the development of the five
dwellings
it is acknowledged that change has
happened in this area however the layout
and historic features are legible
a plan has been provided showing the
site for the dwellings with the historic
buildings
on the site overlaid the areas in dark
grey show the previous buildings on the
site
these
would have been small scale service and
ancillary structures accessed from the
service road
the previous structures are not
considered to set a precedent for
dwellings in this location
this is a photo of hindustan hall which
is grade one listed the site subject of
this application is considered to
contribute to the setting and
significance of this listed hall and its
grade two star listed
stables coach house and brewhouse
this is a photo from the service road
adjacent to the hall which offers views
towards the site
the green roofed building is the
existing green keepers building and the
yellow house is the owner of the golf
club's house
from this viewpoint it is possible that
any future dwellings on the site could
be seen if they were any higher than the
existing wall
place services
heritage and historic england consider
the development of five dwellings in
this location to cause urbanization of
this area and introducing an incongruous
land use in the setting of the heritage
assets
detracting from the manner in which they
are experienced
the dwellings would also bring with it
other domestic paraphernalia and which
could include sheds trampolines etc
which could further urbanize the area
and cause harm to the setting of the
grade one listed building
this map shows
where the photo was taken in relation to
the heritage assets
and shows what direction the camera was
pointing
for reference to the historic
significance of the hall in its setting
these are two thomas gainsborough
paintings which feature the grounds of
hindustan hall we don't know the exact
locations of these paintings on the
grounds
at the committee site visit on the 23rd
of march i was asked to provide details
of planning permissions which have been
granted for hindustan hall
i will now run through some of these and
explain why
they were approved
in 2021
permission was granted at hindustan hall
for the erection of building and
courtyard development west are the
stables and coach house to provide
additional spa facilities gym pool sauna
steam room following the removal of an
outbuilding the area in blue shows the
land in the ownership of hinduism hall
and the aryan red shows the location of
the development
which is adjacent to the grade two star
listed part of hindustan hall
you can see the golf club to the north
along with the site subject of this
application
this is the
um approved block plan
uh the dark grey area being the new
element
this is the approved north facing
elevation
east facing elevation
south facing elevation
and west facing elevation
this development was approved following
extensive engagement with the heritage
team and historic england
the new structures were supported as
they are concentrated within an existing
cluster of structures of an area of the
stables
which have formerly been occupied by
buildings
although the new buildings take a
different form
the
courtyard element is the traditional
design and the scale of the buildings
are smaller than that of the existing
historic buildings the development also
supports the hall's hotel business by
allowing them to offer more facilities
which goes hand-in-hand securing the
future viability of the hotel and
thereby securing the repair and
maintenance of the significant and
important historic building
in 2019 permission was granted at
intersim hall for the erection of a
single-story function room which would
be ancillary to the hotel this plan
shows the approved block plan with the
function room on the right-hand side of
the drawing
this is the southwest elevation
northeast elevation
southeast elevation
and northwest elevation
this application was granted following
engagement with the heritage team in
historic england
a moderate level of lesser substantial
harm was identified however with
amendments to the design and materials
both heritage and historic england
removed their objections
in 2017 permission was granted at home
wood which is in the same ownership of
the land of the golf course and
surrounding agricultural land for the
change of use of land for the direction
of four safari tent holiday type units
with associated parking and landscaping
this plan shows a site location in red
and the blue line shows the land in the
same ownership
this plan shows the design and locations
of the holiday lodges
this application was granted following
extensive pre-application advice with
heritage
as well as continued engagement
throughout the application process
as a result of an objection from
heritage and historic england the number
of units was reduced from eight to four
and as the units would be set down into
the bowl of homewood within a heavily
wooded area it was not considered to
cause any adverse harm to the setting of
the listed buildings or the historic
park land
the holiday units also offer benefits
for tourism in a rural location
therefore supporting the rural economy
in 2016 permission was granted at hindu
gym hall for the erection of a two-story
building to form eight bedroom suites
adjacent to the orangery building
the plan
shows the approved location and you can
see the site subject of this application
to the north and hendersham hall to the
south
it should be noted that this development
has not been completed
this shows the approved block plan which
connects eight more bedroom suites to an
existing building that provides bedrooms
for the hotel business
this is the approved southeast elevation
you can see it is slightly set into the
land
northwest elevation
southwest elevation
north east elevation this application
was granted because the development was
considered to be in keeping with the
other new additions and further extends
the accommodation and functionality of
the hall without harming its historic
fabric
although the development was identified
to cause less than substantial harm it
was outweighed by the benefit of
providing an increased income to support
the business and supplement the running
of the grade one listed hall
thus providing viability and maintenance
of the significant and important list of
buildings
although the application for the golf
club would provide financial support for
the business it would not secure the
maintenance and viability of a grade one
listed building like some of these
applications have
and the public benefits are not
considered to outweigh the moderate
level of less than substantial harm on
this basis
i will now go through some photos of the
site and its surroundings
however the majority of you have seen
the site when we visited on the 23rd
this is a photo of the entrance road
again this is the entrance road looking
towards the hall
it's largely screened by trees from this
viewpoint and you can see agricultural
land on the left hand side
this is a photo of the grade one listed
hall
this is a wider view of the hall you can
see its car park in front of the grade 2
star listed elements
this is another photo of the hall
looking towards the car park
and it's great two star listed buildings
this is the photo from the entrance road
adjacent to the car park looking towards
the site the green roof building is the
existing green keepers building and the
yellow house is the owner of the golf
club's house
this is a photo looking towards the site
from the entrance to the golf club car
park
there is a small opening which at the
moment allows the views into the site as
well as above the wall where there is no
tree line
this is a photo of the green keepers
building and the site for the five
dwellings
you can see the existing house
in the background and the wall
and this is a wider view of the site for
the dwellings with the existing green
keepers building you can see the wall at
the back
where there isn't a tree line
and the recommendation is refusal thank
you
thank you very much rose
do you have any questions from members
for the
officer councilman
thanks rose quite a long presentation
that one um
really glad we had a site visit i think
it was pretty essential for this the
complexities of this site so
regarding the outstanding existing
permissions can i ask how determination
was made on those uh decisions
they were delegated decisions to my
knowledge they didn't go to committee
um so there are cumulative effect of
five applications i can count there and
as far as i can see they all lie between
the site and the uh listed heritage
assets
um would that be correct
in a line of sight basically one end to
the other we all lie closer to the
heritage assets
yes that's right they are all very close
to the heritage assets
actually james
thank you
the driveway that goes from the main
road up to
um hillstrom hall and to the gulf coast
you say the golf course have got access
rights on that who owns that driveway
and could those rights do we know those
rights could be
rescinded i believe um the
owner is hindusham hall of that access
way um and the the golf club does have a
right of access over that i'm not sure
if they could revoke that access
answer barrett
can we look at slide 48 again
please
either 30 48 or
36 would
do that's the one that will do
so um we're told here that there's
obviously um
a problem with the view
the only thing i can see is a great big
pylon
the other thing that i'm concerned about
is that would obviously then the with
what's coming through
we're going to get another pile on the
same size which i think is considerably
more damaging to the um position of the
grade one listed building rather than
the height of a possible five
properties
so
presumably we would get another pylon
if we're looking at it like that
i'm not 100 sure where the additional
pylon would go in the twin steady
absolutely it's within that area because
it's we've seen we've already seen that
yeah so it would run along uh past
behind how how does that square with you
then um with the
i mean that could be substantial harm as
opposed to more
i mean where do we sit on that one
because i just
if we're worried about the height of the
buildings
my concern is more the fact
we've got a great big pile on coming
through
i'll get the uh chief paying officer to
answer that
i mean it's not totally relevant but i
think it's worth pointing out
um
chairman i think i'd always encourage
committee to decide the application in
front of them not something else and
that's what i'd advise here and now um
you're not looking at an application
that relates to
other works
you've got an application which is an
outline application and i think from
what i've seen of the indicative plans
there
um
sorry um
single uh and one and a half story
dwellings together with the uh
functional building
so i'm not sure the point about heritage
harm is solely about
height
and as to pylons and other developments
i
i would decide this application on its
merits and not try to dice decide others
jim thank you i thank you for the chief
manager for keeping me back in line
which is exactly where i need to be but
i just point out that when we're talking
about heights which was actually
commented on in rose's presentation uh i
think that just demonstrates what we're
talking about in terms of height
thank you any more questions to the
opposite answer mclaren
thank you chair
rose you were at great pains to mention
at each development that was in
hindustan hall
that it was done in conjunction or in
discussion with heritage
were the current applicants actually
advised
to have some discussion with heritage
before they submitted their plans thank
you
so pre-application was undertaken for
this
and in the pre-application heritage were
not consulted
and but it was advised to speak
specialist heritage advice given the the
proximity to the
the whole
thank you john
thank you chairman um
one of the proposed benefits is a site
for a tree nursery hundred thousand
trees do we know who or how that will be
run
uh the land in which the tree nursery is
proposed it is leased by the owners of
the golf club
uh i'm we don't have any details of how
that would be run or managed at this
stage
that's about here another question yeah
i mean i might
missed it in the report but how do we
differentiate the harm from the five
outline permissions as opposed to the
harm or no harm for the green keepers
workshop
it has a differentiation is that because
it's a business
so the the heritage bodies
play services heritage and historic
england assessed the no harm for the
green keepers building on the basis that
it would um largely follow the design of
what is already there and would be
pushed further back behind
trees
so there would be um
no harm on that basis
any other questions
nope in that case thank you very much
rose
and we'll move on
public speakers
i understand that we have an objector is
that correct player
and it's mr ben borthwick
you have three minutes to address the
committee thank you
thank you chair members i'm ben
borthwick of smith jenkins town planning
consultants acting on behalf of our
client the hindustan hall hotel our
client operates this four star two
rosettes hotel immediately adjacent to
the application site
our client objects to the application
and fully supports your office's
recommendation to refuse planning
permission the reasons set out in the
report
i have circulated letter to members by
email which received reiterates the
comments set out on our written
objection submitted to the council back
in september 2021 this letter also
provides additional comments in respect
of the officers committee report in the
interest of brevity i will not attempt
to repeat all these points made in our
letter however i would like to emphasize
a number of points
the application site is located outside
the built-up boundary of hiddleston
village and is therefore within
countryside where in local plan policy
cs2 allows development only in
exceptional circumstances
it is clear that the enabling
development case promoted by the
applicant whereby the sale of land for
the dwellings will fund maintenance
improvements of the golf club is
markedly different from the case that
supported new residential development at
phoenix stowe ferry golf club which is
mentioned in the officer report
here the proposal included very
significant public benefits including an
increase in local jobs and other
tangible benefits to the local economy
as well as attracting increased
membership through the creation of a new
putting green and other facilities this
is not the case with the application for
you
the felix stow proposal was also
considered to be sustainable development
because it represented a partial reuse
of previously developed land adjacent to
the built-up area of a large town this
is in stark contrast to the proposed
housing at hindustan golf club which
apart from the dwelling proposed at plot
number five would be located on
undeveloped land within the countryside
the applicant has failed
to provide any assessment of local
housing need to justify the proposed
five houses on land outside a defined
settlement boundary in the context that
labor district council is able to
demonstrate well in excess of five years
of housing land supply this is contrary
to nppf paragraph 78 which supports
housing development in rural areas that
reflects local needs
the statutory council t response from
english sorry from historic england
raises strong concerns to the
residential element of the proposals on
heritage grounds historic england
considers that the application does not
accord with paragraph 199 or with
paragraph 200 of the mppf
furthermore place services heritage
advises the proposal also fails to
comply with the requirements of mppf
paragraph 206.
to conclude i would urge members to
refuse plan permission on the basis of
our clients significant concerns which
fully support your office's
recommendation in the report thank you
are there any questions
counselor baron yes you said your
clients concerns uh is it that they're
building
or the developments within
their
grade one listed building
primarily yes impacts on on on historic
buildings and the landscape
so you're not concerned that your last
five applications have been within that
curtain as well
i think my point on that was every case
is determined on its merits i wouldn't
like to comment on history of the hotel
development because we're looking at
this application
thank you
any more questions
nope
thank you very much
moving on
do not have a supporter no
no but we do have
the agent mr philip branson
and the owner
column
between you you have three minutes to
address the committee
good morning alan connell
we purchased hinters from golf clubs 16
years ago when it had less than 200
members and few public facilities
since then substantial improvements have
been made resulting today in a viable
inclusive and thriving facility which is
available to all especially the local
community who benefit from free social
membership there are now over 600 golf
members and 300 social members
we are more than just a golf club and
cater for all types of leisure occasion
and we are an integral part of hindustan
itself a range of facilities match any
golf club in suffolk many of whom are
privately owned member clubs who impose
restrictions on access by the general
public which is not the case at
hindustan golf club
whilst profitable due to economic
conditions hindustan golf club has not
been able to generate sufficient cash
over the last five years to maintain the
required level of capital expenditure
despite spending nearly a million pounds
on capital expenditure over the last 15
years by reinvesting profits and
borrowing we currently have a backlog of
important expenditure
the most significant being the
rebuilding of our green keepers workshop
and storage building which is falling
down
we can cope with future capital
expenditure but need a lump sum to clear
the backlog hence the reason for this
enabling application
where we held pre-application
discussions and have followed the advice
given we are however shocked at the lack
of understanding and empathy shown to us
during this process and the comments in
the report to the committee-like
underlined privately owned hindustan
gold club and the benefits will accrue
to the private rather than the public
ninety-five percent of all golf clubs in
england are privately owned ipswich golf
club over woodbridge stone market stoke
by nyland and of course felix slow ferry
are all privately owned felix stowe a
member-owned golf club is held as a
paragon of virtue for providing a
putting green and a cafe as part of
their planning yet hindustan already
provide these facilities to the public
and will continue to do so
ladies and gentlemen this is a worthy
application it will not harm the
heritage assets in any way the
development is out of sight and hearing
of the hall which is well over 200
metres away
it is only 600 metres away from the
village as mentioned in the report in
other words just a seven minute walk or
a third of a mile is that excessive i
think not
we need to embrace the future not live
in the past dreaming about the mythical
hinduism park which has not existed for
three quarters of a century
indeed for the last 35 years it is a man
he could it is the manicured golf course
which has provided the beautiful
backdrop parkland backdrop the hall now
enjoys
this is a sustainable development and it
will provide more employment and i ask
you to support it and the ongoing
viability of a valid asset within
bayburg and just to confirm there are no
right to revoke our right-of-way over
the driveway we own part of it in any
case
and um our lease on the small piece for
the land of trees is on the same terms
as our main lease which is 99 years from
1989 i.e 66 years remaining thank
thank
you
are there any questions mr cohn
councilmember
thank you chair
i'd just like to ask and i think it was
already raised about to get some clarity
in the management and operation of the
tree nursery
and how you ensure that that could be
continued for the future
under the application
we were just asked to provide the land
which we were pleased to do so we have
every right to use the land which i said
is the same length of lisa's our
original lease um it's part of it um
we were not asked any other questions by
uh councillor busby we were asked if we
could offer the land but where we can we
would certainly help we have a green
staff we could we could look after
certain things on a day-to-day basis but
we couldn't take responsibility for the
trees but we would help in any way we
can
so my concern is is literally that for
this to be the positive benefit it's
being described as that there should be
some demonstration as to how that
benefit could be achieved um at the
moment it's a promise and i'm just
asking how we secure that and how you
would
see that view
my understanding was it was something
that the the baby were were looking to
do and they they had arrangements to
manage it not us but we have as i say
we're happy to provide the land which is
not a a free offer sorry it's a free
offer to bayberg it's not free from us
because we wouldn't be able to use it
for for
the things that we're looking usually at
the moment
in that case i just like to ask if
officers can
give any indication as to how that might
be achieved
under this application
hi um
would you consider instead of having
because you've got two bungalows and
then one half
properties is that um because
we do like bungalows in this would it is
it's something you would consider doing
to have them all bungalows
rather than having one and a half
yeah if um
mr brandon could answer that here's our
planning
as as rosa's already said in a report
the application is a hybrid application
um the green keeper's building being
detailed so we've provided the full
details of that the the residential
element is only outlined so at the
moment what you've seen is only
indicative
if a condition
was put on the application on the
consent that required all the buildings
to be single story
that would be something that we'd
obviously have to consider
there is a balance because it's a
viability exercise so there's a balance
that we need to raise an element of
money to to to to invest in in the green
keepers buildings and the other elements
of the of of the improvements to the
club um but
if if um if that was something that the
committee felt strongly about that
single story was the was was was really
what you'd like to see there and happen
and that reduces any
chance of any heritage harm then would
be happy to consider it
thank you
any further questions
answer him
just a quick point of clarification
really um rose mentioned
some tented holiday accommodation
scattered about in there in one of the
woods
uh are those under the control of the
golf course or are they part of the
hiddleston hall they're not they're not
they're nothing to do with us
a landlord i.e the person who owns the
freehold of our lease um his family i
believe um run that and own it uh we we
have just provided them with the right
of way along our at our track expertly
it's completely separate and we're not
in control of that
anymore
if not thank you very much
and we'll come back to council mcgraw's
question would you like to repeat it
yes i was just wondering what mechanisms
if we were inclined to
set a condition
on the
tree nursery uh what what what
arrangements could be made to ensure
that
it actually happens if it's going to be
described as a benefit it needs to be in
my view uh
to be achievable and and to be
manageable um in in the long term tree
nurseries um can't just be done for six
months or a year or two they take time
for the trees to grow
um chairman if i start um rose if you
could get up the slide which shows the
area in question just so we know what
we're talking about um
i was going to suggest that if um you
needed to help in maintenance of the
thing
we wouldn't be against that if it helped
in any way
you have to establish fine i think
what the benefit will be to the public
as considered by
the planning officer on in terms of the
payout
thank you
thank you chairman um
so rose you've got a tree nursery zone
shown on that plan do we have any other
uh drawings to show the extent of that
area
no just this is this drawing for the
tree nursery zone
thank you rose
so as i understand it council mcgraw
the offer is of a dedicated area for
baber to plant and grow on trees
as part of our objective to
plant ten thousand trees
i don't have any more detail around that
um
the question whether that is a public
benefit it certainly appears to be a
benefit to the council whether that's
public benefit is an interesting point
the land is outside the application site
and is subject to a lease so clearly
there is going to have to be some
element of
understanding of a commercial
relationship about this
um i'm afraid i have more questions than
i have answers about what may or may not
there is a benefit whether it is public
i think is
far from certain to me
thank you
any more questions no
move on then
thank you very much
um
board member
no
no more public speakers
no more public speakers
um
councillor busby has not submitted a
report
to the committee but i believe you've
all been in receipt of
some words from him
over the last day or two
yes okay
and that's we'll leave it at that at
this stage
okay i will now open it up for the
debate would somebody like to kick
things off
go to jameson
i think he's here
um a lot has been made about the
public benefits
to this development but to me the
there are a few public benefits but the
main
uh benefit beneficiary of this are the
golf course and the golfers
the
development is outside the village and
it's
the village doesn't need there is no
local need as far as i'm aware of these
houses
i'm struggling to see
how we can go
against plus as as has been made clear
by heritage in history england they're
they're they've got no
um
recommendation for approving this so at
this stage i can't really see
or i can't see going against
myself going against the
the um officer's recommendation
cash mccrory you were waiving first and
council byron yeah um
i have to say i'm really glad that we
had the opportunity for a site visit um
because it was invaluable to see the lie
of the land
and particularly the lines of sight
running from the
the development site
and the heritage assets
and the distance between them
the amount of screening that existed
and has been as having pointed out the
number of existing planning permissions
that seem to me to be
potentially of a greater impact on the
heritage assets
i understand the decisions made um
for viability for the
uh hindusham hall
itself
i don't see why some of the liability
matters shouldn't be applied to
hindustan hall golf club which of course
two separate businesses
and and clearly not entirely on a same
page on this one but that's not our
problem our problem is looking at the
planning balance and i think the
interesting point is and having seen the
site again this is crucial because the
planning balance was very much you know
where we are engaged the amount of harm
as described on the scale
as being a moderate level of less than
substantial harm
came
bang in the middle of that 180 degree
graph putting it right up up the center
whereby this is where a planning
committee comes in we go one way or the
other way based upon our judgment as to
what the overall benefits to the public
and and
to and as opposed to
planning principles across the board we
have a duty of looking out for um
prosperity as well as
as design and and impact now the point
on impact
was and i was particularly noting this
was that the site where the houses uh
are going to be contained is entirely
screened by trees in fact it's um it's
more
screened than anywhere else in the
surrounding area
as long as those trees are retained
which i would suggest
we ensure should we be minded to grant
any permission i would suggest we have
those trees retained
then you have a wall then you have the
owner's property the yellow house then
you have the existing one two or three
planning permissions before you even get
close to the central building intelsham
hall the grade one listed
so
then it comes down to so if that balance
is engaged and i think it is engaged
about the benefits i think it is
important as to what those benefits are
um
i don't accept that keeping that golf
club is nothing because i mean it is
providing facility 900 people are being
served 300 social members i think 600
actual members that sounds to me quite a
decent number uh in a community the size
of hindustan as far as i can see
existing um heritage harm
nothing not excluding the pylons is
already far more than severe
i'm actually moving and having seen the
site i think was crucial i'm actually
moving my part of the center
planning balance moves in favor of
granting permission uh it's very well to
suggest that the green keepers
could be given permission but not the
houses one won't take place without the
other the green keepers cut can't take
place unless it has the enabling
permission for the housing we could make
conditions on the housing perhaps by
reducing the height
for some or all of them
but i'm not entirely convinced by the
heritage argument here and that that's
that matter of less than substantial
harm being in the center
i would say as long as we can secure all
those benefits i want to see something
more on the nurseries but i do think we
actually have a have a literally right
in the middle balance question here
thank you councilman i i think the chief
paying officer
if i'm a chairman and
um
any description of heritage harm you
ever end up tying yourself in knots with
in my experience
your starter for 10
should be and this is required in the
nppf
before you consider all of these other
questions is to give great weight to the
conservation of the asset
so you may have a series of planning
provisions that exist but you are
deciding this application
today
on the circumstances you have before you
and the more important the asset the
greater the weight you attach to that
conservation and what we have here is a
part grade one part grade two star
asset the whole
so
the starter the starting principle
putting it in in layman's terms is to
give great weight to protecting those
things
then you come to this question of
weighing the less than substantial harm
test and lawyers have played with that
over
plenty of time and you are in a point
where you you have to have public
benefits engaged and i would suggest you
those need to be quite serious public
benefits for that to engage even with
the balance that rose described and
opinions will differ about what that
actually means
but the heritage test starts with
conserving the asset you've talked again
about scale and other matters
as a piece of advice to any committee
looking at an outline application in the
setting of a heritage asset i would be
most most careful you have no certainty
about reserve matters but once you say
yes to the scale of something
it's gone you cannot revisit that is
that reasonable i question that so
i understand what you're describing
about balance
but please
i would remind committee you start from
the first principle that is great weight
attaches to conserving
the asset and here you have assets which
are at the higher end of importance
nationally thank you
is the chief planning officer then just
to clarify that um
you won't mention we we are
should be careful to secure um at
outline because once it's gone it's gone
can we secure any conditions on the
scale of those buildings for example as
bungalows has been mentioned is that
within our gift and and with that
answer part of that question in terms of
impact on the heritage acid
so my advice to you
chairman or my advice to committee is
that you shouldn't really be looking at
an outline application which does not
give you the certainty to assess all of
the potential elements of it detailed
design scale layout all of the elements
that would be reserved matters i think
if i'm if i'm putting this simply i
would expected to see this as a full
element of an application if you were
expected to make a decision in its favor
today outline creates too much
uncertainty for a committee to reach a
conclusion over in my opinion
on that point then chair is it possible
to defer it until the full application
can be brought forward so that we don't
have any hybrid element
is that possible i'm only asking the
question
i mean are we obliged to decide
it is always possible but let's hear
some more that's fine okay i just wanted
to ask the possibility
counselor haron you were
wishing to speak
chairman yes thank you um
despite what's been said with the
officer i think we're charged here today
to make the very best decision we can
bear and all these other things in mind
as somebody who works sort of on
sites and within the industry i um
i find heritage a hard one trying to
preserve something that's
quite largely already gone
i might not quite be in favour of that
and i think we do have to take into mind
what's already happening and
happened with
hindustan hall itself
so i'm
it's a hard one it's a rock and a hard
place chairman um
also
there's the benefit to the business um
they say that um they're not going to
attract maybe any more new business
throughout this but then we have a
responsibility i think um
for preserving what's there already as
the business
um
we may not
enhance it for the future this time
around but um
if we don't do the right thing today
there may not be a business or jobs at
all
obviously
leisure industry has been through a hard
time
i'll be interested to hear what people
say but at the moment i would providing
the five dwellings didn't and we can
condition that
i'd probably be well in favor of um
of granting
this application you know i hear
everything that said i've heard it so
many times before when i've sat on this
committee but
um
i think sometimes you've just got to do
the right thing at the right time so at
the moment if somebody's prepared to
propose it i would
certainly prepared to second it we will
have um
visit reserve matters later
so we would get another bite of the
cherry then but at the moment i'm
leaning very well in favor of um
passing this application chairman
and i i
will come back later i would say
thank you councillor horan
i will make a comment myself we've none
of us are picking up on the point from
cancer jameson about there being no need
for these houses and the objection from
the village itself to the urbanization
of this particular area and i'm
very much would like to hear what other
people's comments and that is as well as
as the heritage councilor barron you
were next
yeah thank you um
i i what i find i have a problem with
this is the inconsistency of the uh the
planning process in terms that you've
got
buildings um substantial buildings being
built closer to the grade one listed
asset
um
and this is further away
probably i mean this is where i find the
inconsistency of the planning process is
very annoying um and then we're told we
can't do that but i think at the end of
the day the planning committee i think
we mustn't be
you know we are the man on the clapham
omnibus we are there to look at this
with a fresher set of eyes
and
a reasonable approach to it
um we're not just rule based i know
planning is rule based but i think
within those rules there is certain
areas which make it
very
easy for us to go down and bear in mind
this is an outline permission all we are
giving is a principle of development
nothing more access and principle that's
what outline is and they are they're
demonstrated there so what you've got to
what we've got to do is just look
whether
we it's not totally outlined it's a
hybrid application it's only outline on
the houses i think i need to point them
out too i know and i'm talking about the
houses
i'm not talking about because they
recommend there's a recommended this is
what is even more bizarre so we have a
recommendation for approval
of a workshop which is you know next
door to an application which apparently
is not acceptable
within the whole heritage thing i mean
i find it really difficult to
how you justify
putting approval on one and
refusal on an outline but looking at the
outline application all we're looking at
is the principle of development and the
access to that development which is
clearly there
um
[Music]
and i and i think um
the
elements of those previous applications
which were outside the built-up area
boundary but have managed to be approved
negates the argument that was put
forward about this being outside the
built-up area about where's the
consistency in the approach
i'll ask the
area finally managed to comment yeah yes
chair i just want to pick up on the
the analysis of historic england's
comments i think it's worth just looking
at them again if members could because
they're quite reasoned i do understand
comments about other things have been
allowed quite often those were for the
betterment of the listed building itself
so that was the balancing act then
but but historic england has
stated
that
it doesn't oppose the green keepers
lodge being relocated because
the the line of sight
element is not so critical it would be
behind where it is now and therefore the
heritage harm for it would be less than
it is now so that's why they're
comfortable with that
uh their issue with the
with the housing um
well i'll read this paragraph there is
some erosion in character of the
non-designated parkland surrounding the
buildings but
the legibility of association between
the hall stables wall garden parkland
behind is still apparent
the houses would erode this and alter
the hierarchy of users on the site
and therefore that's the harm so that
that's their reasoning there
it's worth maybe looking at what was
said and looking at the detail behind it
rather than
making general statements about heritage
matters i think
thank you
james the newest
just with regard to the previous
developments that have been brought up
now
if i understand it correctly and
whatever the rights or wrongs of
approving those developments they were
for
to to build areas that would generate
ongoing investment into the whole
on a continual ongoing basis
um this development this these houses as
far as i can see are going to be a one a
one almost a one-off lump sum
um to cover shortfalls they've already
got
when that money's spent
and if they run short again are they
going to come back with a further
area of land they're selling off to for
more development
yes
come to rowan then comes the hidden
you
i think if we mind to
accept this we've got there's got to be
a lot of conditions on it i i don't
think we could just let it let it go
um
it's like
they it hasn't had a flood risk
assessment done on it
and obviously the need
um i am
i am thinking because of hindustan
hall's done a lot of
planning applications and they've been
granted i know we shouldn't be looking
at that
and these are further away i am thinking
more of going with this but only because
i can't see
so much harm but there needs to be
conditions if we do go to it i don't
think we could just let it just go i
think
i think the conditions it's got to be
very strong conditions
to this that nothing else can be built
on the land
um
yeah
that's um
that's it really that's all i can say
counselor hinton
thank you mr
chairman recommendation is it's just a
complicated application
excuse me simply because it's a hybrid
um part of it's for full applications
part of its
outline
part of it has
tacit approval
part of it doesn't so it was always
going to be
always going to be a complicated
situation
uh what puzzles me to a certain extent
about it is that um
on page 22 of the report it talks about
the ipswich group patch who whoever they
might be uh didn't respond and the
british horse society didn't respond so
i thought we've not building stables
here we're talking about a green
keeper's shed
so why on earth did they have to be
involved are they a statutory cor
person historic england i can understand
and their comments are quite extensive
but i'll set those to one side for a
moment
uh on the basis that
the recommendation for refusal
includes policies cs2 cs15 of the core
strategy policies cno1 cn06c and 14
local plan as well as paragraphs and
goes on and on and on loads of policies
that this is against
one of the basic policies for
development in our rural communities is
cs11 which isn't actually mentioned here
but
one of the things that is linked to that
of course is a establishing a need a
housing need
well if you look at the annual
monitoring report which i'm sure you've
all got copies to handle we've all been
studying it
adamantly
hindelsham built eight houses last year
we're talking about another five here
how many houses does hindustan have to
build to satisfy a need i'm not
surprised no survey was done i don't
suppose there was a need within the
village um so it's a contrary to that
it's outside the built-up area boundary
these are houses for
individuals to to live in
rather than
part of a anything else so i think that
we should look at our policies rather
more than we should be looking at
almost a certain amount of emotion as to
whether or not something's gone before
and should we be taking that into
consideration
thank you councillors
thanks jack a couple of points to
clarify uh uh councillors mentioned
about the flood risk assessment there is
a section in there which explains what
happened there um
ultimately the
the local lead floods authority agreed
no assessment was required because the
actual developer part site is under the
threshold it includes the track which
took it over the threshold it's really
under so they're they're happy with that
there's an outstanding issue we've got
talked in internal drainage board about
but that's i think we can park that for
a minute um the council hinton cs11 it
was mentioned in the report but it was
felt it's so far from the hinterland
village that it wasn't the right policy
to judge it by instead we look at cs2
and 50.
are you yes thank you chair no i just i
i i concur with uh councillor mcgraw i
think the site inspection visit
was uh and perhaps that's the benef
benefit of site inspection visits i was
very glad to do that
because you got the actual
um
perception of how this development would
look
i i concur with all that's been said
about
the heritage
but
our world has changed in the last two
years whether we like it or not and um
this is a business that wants to survive
uh i understand councillor jameson's
comment that perhaps it
the impact of the sale of the houses
will be short-lived
but i think
its neighbour
has done a lot to
enhance its own business
and so i think this business should be
given a chance to enhance their business
thank you chair
councillors
thank you chair and a couple of things
um i would have liked on the site visit
for us to be able to observe the um
extensions that have been added to
english from hall we didn't see those
have any idea of how they looked
i don't know if that was relevant or not
but because it's been brought up it
would have been nice to have seen them
and the second was on page
23
um on paragraph five it's
it's clear that as a non-designated
heritage asset change has occurred to
the uses of the park land which has been
harmful to the setting of the listed
building but
this should not be used as a
justification for the possibility of
more harm or cumulative harm
so we're back to that bit in the middle
thank you
thank you
any more
comments
uh chairman if i can just come in um
the
uh
issue before you is as i think we
discussed in relation to the nursery
somewhat unclear the applicant as i
understand it
talking about various elements that will
be funded out of this development
we have not uh audited those figures and
or have we any detailed understanding of
whether or not they are proportionate to
what's proposed
um
i think in the circumstances of that
there is an absence of information to
enable you to be confident that this is
no more and no less than what is
required to service what is being asked
of it
so to that extent
i would express some concern about
members
if they
chose to
conclude that permission should be
granted
on the information today
now
there's also elements of the proposal
here which are outside the application
site drainage irrigation across the
course is described
there's
a number of elements to this which are i
think ill-described in the application
and left for you to
draw your own conclusions over we talked
about the nursery earlier and i
uh i think we don't have certainty as
officers in what the position is with
those
um
in the circumstances i think it would be
challenging to reach a conclusion
that planning commission could and
should be granted on the facts as they
stand to get today i do think that if
members are minded to take that view as
is their discretion
the reasonable approach will be to seek
further information around those
elements if that's where they chose to
go and i don't recommend that i think
that you have
a clear recommendation and you have two
technical advisors advising of harm
we've talked a lot about the height of
buildings and its impact on
the experience of heritage asset
that isn't the only test in relation to
heritage assets it is a wider question
um and well i imagine the whole be
extremely interested in as they're
sufficiently interested to send somebody
here today to observe proceedings and
contribute
so i think you've got quite a lot of
challenging contexts
if members are inclined to support this
as a development
there are lots of elements to it one of
which we have touched on in relation to
the outline aspect
others relate to what
may or may not prove to be public
benefits
and i think
if i was asked i would say that at the
moment you have
a paucity of information to enable you
to reach a conclusion on them in a
reasonable way
so if you're inclined to go in that
direction chairman i know there has been
debate about whether that's a good thing
or a bad thing
i don't think that should necessarily
happen in the context of a substantive
resolution but in the context of a
deferral the committee unminded to take
a course of action
and you know i say that understanding
that there are
significant harms here which should not
be taken lightly
so i hope that's useful gentlemen
absolute crore
well we're coming down to the nub of it
now i suspect um as i understand it the
chief planning officer is suggesting
that if we were minded to grant we
should consider deferring
uh for more information and i think it
would be useful i'll be honest with and
i was hinting at that before in finding
out how whether our public realm for
example would undertake the management
and um setting up of a
a young tree plantation how we would fix
that in um but i also get the impression
that we're being told not to do that
that we should refuse immediately and
that would finalize the whole thing and
i'm not inclined i have to say at the
moment to say no that's it
no
i don't think that that's justified
even though we do have a lack of
information well perhaps we should have
done more to seek it out i don't know
but i would like to have some a bit more
information so i'm i'm lost here i'm
prepared to suggest deferment um for
more information but i'd like to hear
what other members feel on that before
we come to any conclusion as to a
proposal
i i think you're in the situation where
i grew up with my two penny worth and
was at this moment in time that if we
find this is not a satisfactory
application and information short then
we refuse it and ask for a resubmission
at some particular i think deferment may
well just delay what's going to happen
event eventually anyway anyway that's my
two penalties so
councillor owen you're you're
i was going to say our second deferral
but if that's the way national
proposition council hinton come on
uh i'd like to agree with you uh mr
chairman if we refuse this application
the applicant has a chance to come back
with either two separate applications or
more details on the houses or whatever
the information that we seek
could be supplied in that coming back if
we defer it just sort of muddies up the
water a bit and doesn't actually give
anybody any basis to do anything
thank you oscar
i think we'll hear you over the
conversation going on behind you
yeah thank you mr chairman i i tend to
agree with you and councillor hinton
deferral will be uh getting away from
the point that we need to make a
decision
and um
3.17 of
the
of the report
i think does speak
volumes about uh where we should be but
obviously uh
i do not agree with a deferral thank you
any more coming
counselor here
if nobody else is commenting mr chairman
can i propose the officer's
recommendation
thank you do you have a seconder
i'm so jameson thank you
is there any more comments to make
before we move to a vote
thank you just before you go to that can
i have you
too there's no problems with that in
terms of the wording that you've seen
from the doctor's recommendation we just
go ahead
uh no chair unless you want to
put something right at the end saying
that there's interviews you seem to be
suggesting that you might be able to
come back with a with a better scheme
and it might be okay if that is your
view then i don't i yeah in that case
let's stay mine again
okay so we have a proposal of the
and we're going to go to the vote
thank you chair so members uh
the vote is
now there you are voting for
refusal or not
councillor horan
thank you
councillor barrett yes
uh
thank you members chair we have five
votes for refusal and five votes against
thank you chair so that is
carried as a refusal
thank you everyone
right we have one more can we take a
five-minute break please
thank you welcome back all
um we will move on to the next item
which is dc2106805
land east of the constable country
medical center heathrow east bergholz
and the presenting officer is
sam samantha
thank you chair and uh good morning
members
uh the application comes to committee
for transparency
because of the controversial nature of
this particular site
uh this is also a major application
because the scheme is for more than 415
dwellings
the application is the land east of the
constable country medical center on
heath road in east bergot
the application
site is shown in the hatched area
and receive
outline planning permission for a
mixed-use development of up to 75
dwellings a preschool and a neighborhood
hub comprising a swimming pool office
space and a local shop
public open space and associated
infrastructure were also included in the
outline permission
b1601092
the reserve matters
were received in 2020 and granted by the
planning committee uh
last year this included access layout
scale appearance and landscaping
the application before members today is
a section 73 application to vary two of
those conditions of the reserve matters
application
the application seeks to amend the
operation and delivery times of the shop
and also the construction hours of the
development
the application site is located on the
edge of the village on heath road
i'll just go back aside
we have
the high school up here
in this area
there are open fields
to the east and south of the site
and we have the medical center located
just here
and then the dwellings of richardson's
road
share the boundary just along here
the site location plan shows a bit more
clearly the relationship of the existing
development to the application site
there are dwellings
on richardson's road
and medical center
just along this boundary to the west
here
this plan shows the constraints of the
site
the site is outside of the built-up area
boundary which is shown by
the brown line that you just might be
able to see just along here
there are public footpaths to the north
just here and here
they showed with the green dotted line
and there's also a footpath to the south
just here which is known as the donkey
track
these green areas are the areas of
outstanding natural beauty
uh this is the site layout the members
agreed for the reserve matters
application
uh there is a landscaping belt around
most of the boundaries
there's an attenuation pond just here
the dwellings are located in this area
here
and then the neighborhood hub is up in
this northwestern corner of the site
just here near the medical center
and we have the preschool here
swimming pool here
and then the shop just here
looking at the neighborhood hub in a
little more detail
you can just see those buildings again
with the preschool here
swimming pool and then the shop just
here there's also a delivery bay for the
shop located in this area here
the scheme includes 26 affordable
units eight of these are actually flats
above the shop
so
therefore the prime consideration of
this particular application is
residential immunity and how extra
opening times of the shop and the
deliveries may impact particularly these
flats above the shop but also some of
the surrounding dwellings around the
site as well
the application seeks to vary the
wording of two conditions
where specific times have been
restricted
condition seven concerns the operation
times of the shop which were restricted
to between 8 am and 8 pm with no
deliveries outside of those areas
members may remember that at the reserve
matters
committee meeting
it was discussed that perhaps
we should be a bit more lenient about
the timings
for the shop at that stage everything
had already been considered and we would
have needed to go out to reconsultation
so that's the reason that this
application has been received
after the reserve matters just to
clarify the opening times and to change
them slightly
condition eight of the reserve matters
are concerned the construction hours uh
which were restricted to eight am to six
pm on mondays to friday
and nine am to one pm on saturdays with
no working on sundays or bank holidays
dealing with condition 7 for the shop
firstly
the applicant wanted to change the
opening hours to 6 a.m to 6 p.m with
deliveries outside of those hours
the parish council environmental health
and the strategic housing team
all objected to those hours on the basis
that before 7 a.m in the morning is
considered to be night time
and therefore noise before this time is
anti-social
particularly delivery vehicles with
engines running and some with
refrigerated units on board
making noise in a very residential area
the parish council helpfully provided
the opening hours of the co-op and post
office store in the centre of the
village which are 7 a.m to 10 p.m
the applicant was sent has sent written
confirmation that he is agreeable to
these revised hours
um with also the deliveries being made
within that time frame and not outside
which would be considered to be night
time hours
at the time of writing the committee
report the revised hours were still a
consultation with uh with the parish
council environmental health and
strategic housing
we have received all of those responses
now and they are in your table papers
for you to be able to see what has been
said
all of the objections have actually been
removed and they are content with those
opening hours of 7am to 10 pm
dealing with condition 8
the construction hours
the condition restricts working hours on
the construction site to be between
8 am to 6 pm monday to friday
and 9 a.m to 1 p.m on saturdays with no
working on sundays or bank holidays
the applicant has applied for a change
to the weekday hours by increasing the
working hours by one hour in the morning
with working hours beginning at 7am and
finishing at 6pm
and then environmental health raised
concerns over the additional hour saying
that there wasn't justification for that
extra hour however the parish council
did not object
to to the to the extra hour in the
morning
and officers considered that the
additional hour would not be harmful to
residential amenity because the site is
not in a built-up area
it's a very large site and it's likely
that in that first hour the workers will
be setting up and getting their things
together before they start any noisy
processes
it is for a limited time only just
during construction
the application is recommended for
approval with all conditions from the
reserve matters permission being carried
over to this section 73 application
uh legal advice is being sought at the
moment on whether a supplementary deed
is required
which would ensure that
this section 73 is bound to the original
section 106 agreement
and that nothing is missed out on there
if a new deed is required
the decision will be held back until
that has all been signed and sealed
thank you
thank you son
any questions for the opposite
answer
thank you thank you son very detailed i
was just looking at the page 54 3.9
um and in the um second sentence it said
there should be no delivery so the
development arranged for outside of
these hours unless otherwise agreed in
writing
and i seem quite nebulous
i just wondered could come back with
that thank you
yeah so that does enable us to be able
to
do that through a written uh
agreement rather than having to keep
having applications coming backwards and
forwards
however because
this particular
the issues around residential immunity
we felt that it was best to actually
submit an application because it did
need to go out for a reconsultation
because of the flats above
it's just that i thought in writing um
they could maybe do it every week or
whatever you know would there be no sort
of
limit on it
they could do that however they would
need our written permission that they
could uh change the hours at all so we
still remain in control of that i think
it's unlikely because they've actually
put a proper application in and come
back with these hours but they are still
able to do that if they wish
council yeah that um that's
that practice has been sort of
discredited leaving those words and i
checked it i didn't add those wording
out we should just take that out it
doesn't really say anything if they want
to change the condition they have to
apply to change the condition again so
we'll we'll take out that wording about
unless otherwise agreed sorry so i'm
having spot done
i
am the fire rescue asked for condition
16 is that something that's going to
happen or is it thank you
yeah so all of the conditions from the
reserve matters application they will
all be carried forward so if there was a
requirement for fire hydrants on the
reserve matters application that will
still be carried forward to this one
any more questions
no thank you very much sons
do we have any public speakers
no public speakers at all
i presume the ward member you're staying
on the committee but you're going to
open up the debate for us yes please mr
chairman um not an awful lot to to
discuss here uh
personally i think that the the hours of
opening
uh going to be a little bit onerous for
the residents above it but uh it's very
difficult to justify anything more
restrictive than the ones that already
exist on the
co-op in the middle of the village
so it's a pragmatic decision there i
think the construction times bringing it
forward from 8am to 7pm is
useful to a certain extent as it you'll
take quite a lot of the tradesmen's
vehicles
out of the traffic flows
when the children are going to the high
school which of course is just opposite
that site so it will have a safety
impact
improvement in that respect so i i have
no uh real concerns about this these two
changes are conditions there are other
conditions which sam knows about that
i'm
in discussions with her on um but as far
as these two are concerned then i have
no problems with them and i recommend
approval
thank you do you wish to say anything
more no you're just
happy with the second
does anybody want to make a counseling
macro did you know now you're going to
second
anyone else with any comments to me
if not we'd make absolutely sure just
before you vote just to confirm that
we'll remove the words which the
counselor referred to unless otherwise
agreed in writing those will be removed
from condition
seven and otherwise
it says
so yep
take it to a vote
you will
thank you chair members that vote is in
progress council about four
thank you council home
um
um
would you like me to take yours further
thank you
chair that's ten votesville that's
unanimous
okay vote for thank you that's that
passed
thank you everyone for your attendance
the next meeting is scheduled for the
13th of april 2022
here in the chamber
i
now formally close the meeting
thank you
you